what do you think of this hustle it
doesn't have anti hustle it doesn't have
to be crazy at work meme that's going
around so there's a group of people you
and I are both Gen Xers and we came in
after the Boomers and it was kind of
like hey we're gonna have to bust our
asses to you know actually create our
own world and I have this millennial and
Gen Z and it's kind of this like
lifestyle experience is first that's
quite charming but does it have to be
crazy at work do you have to hustle can
you build a Tesla or a Facebook and not
sacrifice a large swath of your time and
life in that pursuit well so there's two
answers to that question
one is you don't have to sacrifice
everything but it depends what your
ambition in life is there are a lot of
people who want to change the world
there are some people who want to build
the next Tesla Facebook a better
Facebook whatever those tend to be
incredibly difficult exercises there's
people who want to be NBA basketball
players and there's people want to be
high school basketball players if you
want to play you know on the NBA
all-star team you're probably committing
a lot of your time to practice you're
probably working out you're probably
eating while you're sleeping you're and
you're taking 500 shots a day typically
500 shots a day is incredibly draining
100 shots per day for me this is
incredibly draining but they if you
wanted monotonous yeah like imagine you
want to be a little big gymnast from the
time you're like four years old you do
nothing except train for the Olympics
and so it depends what your goals in
life are but the idea there's no
sacrifice or no trade-offs is crazy if
you want to do unreasonable things and
most of these goals are unreasonable by
any normal definition there's
unreasonable commitments and sacrifices
that come with that and it's up to any
individual what they want to do with
their life you know whether they value X
versus Y but it but to tell people that
they can achieve without the sacrifice
it's just misleading and borderline
fraudulent